I learned actually more from Young
filmmakers today than I do from some of
the older filmmakers that made movies 80
90 60 years ago because some of the new
filmmakers today are doing such
audacious work
um the Daniels such amazing genius work
on everything everywhere all at once and
I'm learning from Young filmmakers so
much but one of the things I'm learning
is you got to have a good script I've
always said if it ain't on the page it
ain't on the stage and I really believe
that and so my advice is to if you want
to be a movie director
first of all right and if you don't feel
that's your strong suit meet somebody
whose strong suit is storytelling and
writing and form a little limited
partnership because because it's the
stories they're going to get an audience
to pay attention to you not the shots